so here's the scene that I was
incredibly proud of as a director but
you know just didn't work inside of the
side of the confines of our of our film
obviously the scene between the
characters a Quay in a copy and I'm in
are making the scene was the attention
for the audience to really realize that
at a Quay and we'll copy were husband
and wife it kind of had a confrontation
argument about where Wakanda was going
to go after the child's death you know
in the in the in the tribal council room
I was it was a scene with the incredible
performances from from from Danai gurira
daniel Kuya but it just didn't working
it in the film but I'm really excited
for folks that folks to see it anyway
you didn't seem to have a problem when
he was thrown from the force
he was the king's challenge he lost to
lose he was not fit to lead each other
told me to my face right here if you
bring claw back did he do it he had him
the Jackass stole him from our I don't
care
crossed off from us he made my mother
and father 30 years there's been not
justice and teacher I swore to bring him
back not taken to the UN no taken to the
CIA but bring him here to us
this is what you would have me leave the
Dora for to bring our children into this
world where they become conquerors yes
that children will be leaders of a truly
free well not just a tiny country where
we have to hide everything that makes us
great there are in war and death but in
the end it will be beautiful makanda
will stand tall
[Music]